[Music]
Andy we're gonna need your help with
this one all right I'm gonna have you
stand in the middle here Conan if you
want to come around side now what you
want to do is just support the body this
is the same kind of snake that Britney
Spears had in her video
did you guys remember that we were
completely lost until you said that
what would the bear have to do with
Britney yeah you know I don't think she
ever did anything with bears the snake
is crushing my forearm is that something
to be said we'll be fine that's the
weekend the strong end down here so
but this is a Burmese python
I'm native to very dangerous aren't they
well that end is not the danger son I
have the danger sad so they crush you to
death yes so it doesn't matter what end
our own strict errs and that's how they
kill their prey they will follow them so
get to your point of why is that and
more dangerous well cuz this is this is
the eating and you have the poop again
so you know it depends on which way you
look at it so that's our your and action
these guys will get to be about 20 feet
23 feet long okay these guys only only
about 14 feet so just you know it's just
a juvenile it's crushing crushing flan
and you don't see it help down there no
I'm fine it's just it's ending it is
very strong and it's crushing the
forearm and Andy's moving wisely away
martyr then I'm gonna sit over here it's
crushing that hand and this hand but you
got something crushed on television they
won't cure you unless it wraps around
your lungs that's actually how they kill
their prey
as long as I gotta worry about why don't
we get you unwrapped here and we'll
bring out our are neck and I'll tell you
what these aren't even the scary animals
then this last one is probably going to
be the most scary
you weren't kidding I thought you were
just gonna fart I was told you three
times
[Music]
all right this next animal in all
seriousness you guys want to be on this
side see a cage on a glove and a bowl of
meat yeah I'm scared you're gonna step
back and if this animal comes close just
stay behind me all right are we ready
this is a cape vulture this is a vulture
this is a vulture
this is the velociraptor look at the
claws let's see if we can get him up
here on the stage hey he's looking the
other way there we go
now he's gonna aggressively come for
this meat so don't let him see that
meatball oh yeah we're gonna kind of
keep you over there why did you carry
him why did you give me a meatball and
then say don't let him see that you have
a meatball you don't want to let him see
it so that he jumps on you so you kind
of hide behind me there right you're
gonna so just hold it near my face there
we go okay hey pal away from the
audience now these guys are scavengers
which is why okay I'm unhappy now
just like
so these guys are they're scavengers
they eat carrion that other animals have
killed and they'd have to be really
aggressive there okay I think he's lost
interest
yeah so do people usually when they're
confronting these animals what weren't
bowls of meat is that the idea then so
normally you wouldn't confront this
animal but oh no but these guys have to
fire bring it on a calendar yeah these
guys like they have to fight off their
other vultures when they're actually
going after a kill so you know a dead
carry an animal okay and that's why you
seen him being so aggressive yeah Norah
all right I'm gonna we're out of time
we'll turn I sense that death is
imminent
[Music]
bowl over there we're gonna be over here
others meet you there too
there's nowhere to go you'll have a do
survive okay he's luring him back no
he's headed to the crowd now now he's
headed back
no but he's smart enough to know don't
get in the cage there we go okay all
right there we go
and now you have got trade okay
[Music]
so nice that you brought a bouncer from
an Irish pub with you well it's been a
joy
Davis visit juice ki thank you so much
for being here that was a lot of fun